jay you also mentioned on your youtube
channel that there was an article on
final draft and it was uh quite
beneficial for you it was from an
oakland screenwriter who used to be a
rapper i guess uh syed crumpler right
and it was called against all odds how a
black writer from the bay area queried
his way to being rept
again that's syed crumpler so he had
some tips and it was uh beautifully
written do you want to go over any of
them or yeah yeah yeah you know
saeed's article was
very very helpful and you know following
his tips is what has led to the
uh requests that i've gotten so far
for my script
um
one of the one of the one of the things
that uh he said which i hesitated in
doing
but he's just like use every
every tool in your in your toolkit like
you've gotta you know
go for it um she's like mention that
you're a black writer
you know or
mention you know uh if you are a queer
writer or you know a latino writer or
what have you you know use that to your
advantage you know mention you know if
you're a woman writer
because managers are looking to
diversify
their roster
so it just makes sense you know lead
with something like that and and it's
just like okay you know let me see what
this person may have to offer
another tip was just to keep it short uh
queries that i had drafted before
reading this article were way too long
way too long you know paragraphs upon
paragraphs it's just like this isn't
good you know i'm sitting here thinking
that all right a five or six paragraph
query
is cool
and it's not
you know site is just like intro
logline outro
thank you
you know with your contact information
of course and i followed that template
as well so it's your quick intro you
know hi i'm an emerging black
screenwriter and i've got a script that
i think you'd like to read
here's the log line
thank you for your time and
consideration
j fingers phone number email address
like seriously like keep it short
and
again it's it's been something that i
think works
you know i know that these people their
time is limited they're getting
a query they're getting an email from
someone that's unfamiliar to them and
they want to be out of that email as
soon as possible so if you can
accommodate them
then they're i think they'll be more
receptive to
to saying okay yeah sure
you got to have a strong log line that
was another thing make sure your log
line is tight
and uh you know he did give tips on
ensuring that the log line works and
those were tips that i applied to
my log line you like the restructuring
and finding that one tidbit
that would um
that would like capture someone's
attention
and uh yeah like i said i think it works
because i've gotten several requests for
uh for my script
i think saeed also said number two make
it personal don't just put dear manager
yeah i mean i think that goes without
saying um
you definitely want to make it
personable you know
not your you know
hi sir hi ma'am dear manager
and
you know nothing even something as
simple as hi or hey
you know
if you you know use a uh mesh you know
hey karen
seriously you know it works it really
works because it already it establishes
that rapport right away you know right
away so
right right
those are great tips yeah great and
we'll put a link to that and then we'll
also put a link to your video too
because you you talked about it on your
channel
how many query letters have you sent out
since you've been in
la um
gosh i've probably
probably sent out
between 20 and 25 i'll say
yeah
and these are emails or u.s mail yeah
these are these are emails emails okay
so we don't do
i yeah i haven't i haven't done the
snail mail thing um there is a manager
out there who i think prefers snail mail
uh
but i haven't query that manager but
yeah sending out emails
so you've done about you said 20 about
you know 20 20 to 25 probably closer to
20 yeah
and you you definitely got the one
response back any others besides that
one yeah i mean i've probably gotten
probably gotten about
eight
responses
yeah probably about eight responses
when you get these responses back do you
put these in let's say an excel document
where
you know to follow up with this person
in a year or whenever right right yeah
so i do have um a spreadsheet and i've
got
the manager's name the company that they
uh work for
uh their email address
uh the type of of uh manager that they
are like if they specialize in like tv
you know or features because features is
really my thing so i'm kind of focused
on that but there may be some managers
who you know diversify they're looking
for kind of everything so i do note that
i do have the date that i query a
follow-up date and um just like a little
space to note
what kind of response if any
and what do you think is the acceptable
amount of time to send out a new query
query letter with a new project um
i'm honestly not sure because this is
this is the first like you know uh query
like round of queering that that you
know i'm doing and i don't want to
follow up with a new
project so soon like after like a pass
or what have you uh like one manager you
know
they were just like this project isn't
for us but feel free to
reach out to us with you know
anything else you may have i didn't know
i mean i just knew that that meant the
door was open to query again but i
didn't know if that meant
next week
[Laughter]
or give them some time so you know i
want to i want to give some time before
i do that
um
as far as like follow-ups i'm thinking
that follow-ups
i'm thinking that maybe like two months
is a good
window
so with that in mind
if i'm just going to query like you know
pitch like a whole new
script or what have you then i'd
probably extend the wait time to maybe
like six months
and is that something that's beneficial
i guess with your writer's group as you
can talk to these other writers and find
out what is
industry protocol
definitely yeah yeah yeah you know and
not just with them but with other
writers that i know the screenwriting
twitter community
you know so yeah
right
because it because it i would imagine it
does hurt if you're if you're too
insistent
yeah i i think it could come across as
maybe desperate seeming desperate
you know and that's not you know
my goal is not to
you know aggravate anyone you know i
want to
build a meaningful relationship and you
know uh build a nice rapport with people
so if the door is left open to you know
maybe query you know with another
project
okay cool you know i'm gonna give you
some time though
you know uh before i before i bother you
again
what are your thoughts on query letters
to be honest i i'm still i'm still not a
fan
um but i i do understand uh and
now that i now that i understand and now
that i feel comfortable in crafting
query letters
uh
i feel like that's a tool in my in my
tool kit that i can definitely use
um
they're not as bad as log lines
[Laughter]
but uh no query letters
i questioned the effectiveness of them
before
but that's only because
my attempts were just terrible
like i said now that i feel that i can
craft
a good query letter
and you know get a response
i certainly understand uh
why they work well i mean because
someone wouldn't send their work blind
without
something it's just like you probably
wouldn't want to send a resume
without some type of cover letter right
exactly exactly
you